[Music]
well welcome everyone to my strategic
class so I wanted to actually use you
guys shamelessly to look at a game of
mine which I bet you know I found was a
very strategic strategically complicated
game kind of difficult to play and there
were a lot of interesting moments and
interesting questions in it so I thought
I would look over that and we'll see if
anything interesting happens
all right so Knight f3
it was a King's Indian I usually
fianchetto kind of lamely sometimes I'll
play out other systems but this is what
I've been doing lately so Kings Indian
e5 so the trend in more recent years is
to either play a system with Bishop a5
mainly Bishop g4 but the main line goes
like a 6-row could be a trying to play
for v5 the positions are very
strategically complex but black plays e5
which is considered somewhat committal
and I play here and the main line which
I'm aware of I was aware of at the time
I should say goes ninety seven white
plays here because otherwise then I can
come out sometimes and then usually
white plays 91 to d3 followed by a four
sometimes and it's just very typical
this this Knight maneuver by the way in
these pawn structures the night often
belongs here so it's a very typical
maneuver one which I would pay attention
to my opponent played here which
actually is a quite a common move but
for some reason I wasn't that familiar
with it at the time and I was thinking
okay well what to do so what occurred to
me in this position is that the main
battle for the opening after this move
after ninety seven it's slightly
different black plays more on the Kings
side with that
but in this line it's not so much about
f5 what is the strategic battle based
around try to identify important squares
what's an important square like why is
that I going to be eight instead of e7
which is I would argue slightly more
typical than a king's inning so when I
try to think about this position I I
felt like blacks ideal setup would be to
put the pawn on e5 and get the knight to
c5 so normally black doesn't like to
play on the Queen side in the King's
Indian
usually I have the Queen side and black
tries to play on the Kings side but
first of all on fianchetto is it's
usually harder for black to attack but
also the bishop doesn't control the
Queen side as well so a little bit of a
double-edged sword but the idea is that
black wants to put her knight on c5 and
eventually yes play for f5 and
essentially fight for the e4 square it's
sort of the idea so I played 91 which of
course is fairly normal trying to play
my idea I could play a four as well but
probably doesn't matter that much black
plays 85 trying to stop b4 ideas it's
important to note by the way that if you
play b4 too early you often allow which
move this is a common strategic theme in
the Kings I mean forget for the moment
that this diagonal is open and E 4 might
be strong eat 494 anyway but just forget
about e4 for the moment what is the
other problem with b4 well if you play
96 and I play b5 then you're absolutely
right the problem is that I'm not
obligated to play b5 i can play a three
even and now your knight looks a little
strange so you have to be careful how
you do it but you are you're on the
right ballpark
so again it's a fairly common King's
Indian theme you challenge those people
and the problem is that I don't really
want to take her push right and I can't
defend it with a three because my rope
hangs so it's kind of a typical thing
where if you played before too early you
run into a five so if you're looking at
it from which perspective almost any
time thank you almost any time you have
to pull it you want to play before you
have to look out for a five so now do
you want to a five so I played rook b1
which is a bit unusual but I'm gonna
explain my reasoning so after E for this
is the main line I looked at before
would be a fairly logical choice right
Knight a six-night d3 and now I thought
black would play 97 followed by Knight d
c5 followed by f5 I don't think this
position is bad for white to me this
looks fairly normal however what I don't
didn't like about it is that all my
opponent pieces make perfect sense I
would rather they struggle a little more
to coordinate their pieces and I didn't
necessarily do anything better I have to
admit what I did is not necessarily
better but I wanted to at least make my
opponent think a little bit
my opponent incidentally was another gem
who's played the Kings and I knew his
Kings new experience was probably a lot
more than mine so I wanted to kind of
throw him off a little so I played this
move which is very typical for these
types of positions so what do you think
my idea is so let's say for example
black plays Knight a6 and whistles
what is the idea think about what's the
key square again c5 what how does rook
b1 contribute to controlling c5
I also like to point out that it's very
important to play 91 first if you play
rookie 1 and a lot Bishop f5 with tempo
and have to move back it's very
depressing so it's important that the
Knights here so I can always play you
for just a side note but but ok what how
do I make it so that after 95 I have a
response
and now believe it or not Black has a
slight problem because of 95 I simply
played before
if 97 I don't play 93 I don't play efore
I just played before and this is a
problem because this night now just
doesn't make any sense so again I'm not
saying that what I'm doing was better or
worse but I wanted to throw my opponent
off a little bit and sure enough he took
up quite a long think here I'd say at
least 20 minutes but he found what I
thought was a pretty decent move this so
what on earth could be his idea and this
is why I like I think the King's Indian
is such an awful opening to teach
beginners or to teach people who need to
learn how to play chess because ideas
like this are typical and in order to
find ideas like this you have to know
exactly what's going on in the position
and what the strategic motifs are so I
again against for any player who's
learning to play chess you know learn a
system where you control the center and
you play normal-ish moves and then you
can go to stuff like this but it's
pretty difficult to to understand all
these maneuvers but we're gonna give it
a shot
so 97 what what is black up to let's say
I play a three seems like a logical move
right not what I did
but what it what could be the idea after
alligator that's possible certainly not
a not a terrible idea but I'm not so
sure it actually helps like I can still
play with beef or maybe you can play
with E for afterwards that might be
interesting I don't know how strong it
is
maybe I should also play with you for I
don't know but um top five is
interesting I can tell you that during
the game what worried me a bit more with
something like this
so completely different direction but
what's the idea
you avoid before because you're taking
advantage of the fact that this see pong
this is something that is one of the
main drawbacks of the fianchetto which
I've learned because I like to
fianchetto but this is one of the things
I hate about it that the c-pawn ends up
weak a lot so I have to play b3 I mean I
could play a move like Queen d3 but now
black just plays here and now I would
say I've lost such a strategic battle
this is what people would say because
Black's gonna put a knight on c5 this is
a weakness my pawns are restricted my
pawns are not connected this is the kind
of thing you almost never want to allow
this is what happens when you basically
lose an opening battle doesn't mean
you're like much worse or anything like
that but your position is not a lot of
fun so you can play b3 but now even if
black just develops normally what's your
idea
this Knight doesn't make sense now
nothing about the position is that
normal and also a4 can be an idea as
well breaking up the pawns entirely so
you see how one little move can make
that big of a difference if black had
played Knight a 6 and a lot of a3 before
this would just be miserable but because
of one little difference now I'm the one
who has to figure out a problem so I
decided to play Eve for basically saying
I'm not putting a net on d3 I'm not
committing anything I want to see what
you're doing and I want to play a useful
move in the meantime so black played
Knight to c5 notice he's not playing
that a6 yet so what's his idea if I play
a3 now
let's say it happens a three trying to
play before
can black stop me
nine a six I can play before right
uh-huh we see our familiar pattern right
and all of a sudden not so easy again I
would say blacks won the strategic
battle more or less because I can't get
in before which is not good this is
basically again as I pointed out before
the structure which you just do not want
to allow and note how this pawn is
really hard to attack so again that's
one of the points of black doing this
first because now this rook still
supports this pawn a4 is still a viable
push so instead I decided to play b3 I
should say I was not happy to play b3 it
meant that in order to play four before
I'd have to play a3 then before and it's
just slow I did not like having to play
this move but honestly I didn't really
find a suitable alternative maybe it
move like Bishop e3 or even just 93 just
trading off a pair of Knights again not
exactly what I want but maybe those
would have been nicer options i've
looked at this i've spent a while
looking at this position and i still
don't know to give you an idea so I just
find that these positions are very
complex and I'm hoping to find someone
who can explain them to me so if you
guys come up with anything do let me
know so black played f5 so here the
question is how to react to this
always a tricky question a lot of people
automatically play up three I'd say this
is depending on the situation can be
normal and there can be a mistake
so 93 is possible one of the possible
drawbacks is that have black exchanges
and brings another Knight to c5 you
might lose some time but I don't hate a
move like 93 the problem you have though
in any of these positions is that
allowing black to take on e4 is kind of
tricky now because it usually if black
ever takes this pawn rather than pushing
past and again this is how you figure
things out strategically what is the
battle around what Square does becomes
the most important if black ever takes
on e4 so say this happens 93 and for
example Knight takes e4 you don't play
a4 guys
what is the battle around
which square
I would say e6 is kind of hard to get to
but it could be important later oh yeah
II for so a black can play like for
example 97 Knight f6 Bishop f5 really
quickly I think I'm gonna lose this
battle and it doesn't mean again it
doesn't mean it's disaster and I can
resign it just means that things are
going blacks way and that's kind of the
way you think of strategy it often
doesn't mean one sides that killing or
that doing that well it usually just
means one side has a more pleasant way
of things so I'd say this is like a you
know positions like this could be say
fairly Pleasant Kings Indian for black
because again I want a knight coming to
e4 and that's just not a really easy
thing to do because if I play f3 my
bishops stuck if I move back and play f3
I just look like an idiot
which I mean that does happen but
ideally I don't want to put my pieces
like that right I want to be able to put
a knight on e4 but how do I do it so
that's why I don't really like this
position for white and I honestly didn't
like my position that much here but I
felt like the only way to try to justify
my play was to play up 3 and just say
you know what if you play at 4 and try
to make me good luck to your buddy I'll
deal with it
but mainly it was just I didn't see what
else to do I thought that if I allowed
takes on e4 black just has a fairly
pleasant game whereas here I thought
that black at least had some questions
to answer so black did in fact play f4
which i think is a reasonable choice so
the second black plays f4 we have a
strategic change right and this is the
key to playing a strategic game well you
have to be able to know when the
position changes when the battles change
remember how the battle is for e4 do you
think the battles for you for now
where's the battle
and keep in mind that doesn't have to be
one answer to this there are usually
many battles going on at once
it's like Game of Thrones just
everywhere well what's one f4 definitely
is a signal what is that four signal
what is black in a play what I'm asking
more is not a specific move but what is
Black's general where's Black gonna try
to play the second black plays at four
the center closes right do you think
blacks gonna try to play on the
queenside
why not
the chain of poems is pointing to the
key that's a real I really like this
rule quite often you want to play where
your pawns are pointing sounds weird and
I know mine are pointing both directions
and blah blah blah
but the other rule is you play where you
have more space almost always in the
Kings Indian White is more space in the
queenside that's my side of the board
you don't get to play on that side
unless I mess up the center sometimes
can be played in like for example a
black had opted to take after if I don't
play f3 then you're playing in the
center right but the second black plays
f4 you're no longer battling over the
center black saying you have more space
there you have more space on the Queen
side eventually I'm gonna lose on the
Queen side but I'm gonna check meet you
first I know it's rude right but that's
kind of what f4 signals anytime in the
Kings Indian often times it happens
right under the opening and that's just
opening you know what black gets the
pawn to f4 white charges on the Queen
side black charges on the Kings side
I personally don't usually like those
positions because first and foremost I
don't like to get checkmated and in
those positions that's kind of the risk
I prefer a game where we're both kind of
battling all over that doesn't mean I
don't play those positions sometimes you
have to but and here I have two right
black played out four I do have a bishop
on g2 which means it's hard to meet me
but it also means it's harder to play on
the Queen side nonetheless after f4
where do I absolutely have to play and
probably I should play very quickly yes
that's my side of the board I have to
get something going on the Queen side
which means which move am I gonna play
because as difficult as this position is
I found this move very easy yeah I went
with a three
before then pawn takes it's very hard to
dislodge anything but the drawback of a
three of course is black can play which
move and it's a move we've already
discussed so the question now is do I
play b4 and push past or do I capture on
a form that is your next decision and by
the way I was burning loads of time my
opponent's burning loads of time this is
often what happens when a position
becomes strategically complex because
we're just trying to figure things out
in the back of our minds if we're smart
which again not always but we know that
we can't use all our time because the
position is going to stay complicated
but these are decisions which are
permanent decisions if I play B four or
five take on a four that's a permanent
decision it's basically I either keep
them closed and maybe try to win a four
pawn or you know I take on a four mess
up my pawns but keep the Queen side open
and again it's it's a decision that's I
don't want to say life or death because
that sounds way too dramatic but it's
basically one is probably much better
than the oven so these are the key
decisions that you have to really focus
on and make again when you're having
this kind of strategic battle with an
opponent so what for before I did not
like before
so Knight b3 annoyed me
at some point
well I had some problems so first of all
I want to be able to just win a four if
I can't win a four by the way I hate
playing before because now this night it
I mean it's nice just annoying
right I don't want this guy in my
territory so I looked at taking this
pawn which is tactically playable but I
thought after rook takes Knight takes my
position was actually quite miserable
this Knight can't move and it's stuck on
the edge of the board
I've lost my dark square bishop and in
all likelihood black can just start
maybe play your move now that there's no
bishop open right so now your move
becomes really strong I think because
Queen g5 and all of a sudden it's like I
have no dark square bishop
I kind of hate my life to be honest so
this I did not want so I wanted to play
here but then even so this takes ideas
just was so annoying I was sitting there
going are there's even Knight d2
sometimes so I saw this I saw these
threats I saw this line and I basically
in my head I just won No and sometimes
that's what it takes like a lot of the
times you have to calculate clear lines
and typically it's better but sometimes
it's just you see certain variations and
you just know what's wrong you just know
I can't allow this this is too much so
bite the bullet Knight takes a four but
one of the things I discovered the more
I looked this position and you could say
I'd lucked out a little bit because they
didn't happen to have it that happened
this way but I actually liked my
position more the more I looked at it
first of all I eliminate one of blacks
only develop pieces black has no
development here and although my pawn
structure got open I don't think that's
the end of the world and the reason why
is because I can still try to play on
the Queen side I can still play for c5 I
can still open things up now if black
had better development
I'd hate my Queen side to give you an
idea a friend of mine who is also a GM
and who plays the King's Indian a lot
knows a lot more about than I do
thought my position was really bad here
and I told them we analyzed this summon
after a while he was like you know and
he's usually a pretty optimistic guy but
he was like maybe not so bad and the
reason why is again because
strategically it looks really
bad butt because blacks not developed
all of a sudden there are different
ideas for both sides so here he played a
move which again my friend hated and I
was a bit surprised by but it's an
interesting move
he played c5 I thought Queen e8 was
actually kind of clever trying to win my
pawn but I can even just play 93 so they
have the pawn I'm gonna play c5 next and
again you're not developed it's kind of
my claim strategically yes Black has
some ideas but if I can just get in c5 I
don't know
life is not so bad I looked at a bunch
of things here g5 I have c5 takes like
this was interesting then I wasn't
exactly sure what to do but even here I
think that the position is quite unclear
in any case because again I'm not saying
you've been playing for advantage I just
want a position I know how to play and
at least I thought here I had it was
double-edged Black has good chances but
I have some chances so he played c5
which I thought was a little bit strange
but it is a common Kings Indian idea
where sometimes you you take a move to
play c5 and it kills any ideas will c5 I
have but I actually have a very annoying
and very simple idea here which just
makes blacks position very difficult
and what you guys are gonna find
obviously so what does blacks next idea
probably in all likelihood so say I were
to play tonight d3 what do you guys
think black would do maybe black plays
g5 I don't know but just as an idea like
say black gets a free move is what I'm
asking what pawn of whites is
particularly weak c4 is kind of hard to
attack though what pawn is very is much
easier to attack yeah so I think that
but if I give black any time blacks is
gonna go after a four so the question is
how do I make it so that a four becomes
not a weakness but a strength
I would like to so how can I do that
what yeah
so I played Bishop t2 with the idea of
putting the pawn on a5 next black plays
here black has to play on the Kings side
right there's no other side black
doesn't get to play anywhere else
it's the rules so a5 now again I'm not
threatening anything but notice how now
all of a sudden this pawn is a real
weakness right which means this Bishop
has trouble moving not that it does is
that many great squares anyway but if
this Bishop gets paralyzed it often
means other pieces also will get
paralyzed it means this rook can't get
out into their game it means this Knight
is gonna have our time getting out so
yes if black had pieces over on the
Kings side I'd be terrified I'd be
shaking in my boots going alright please
do not make me but because black has no
pieces out and because blacks pieces are
tied up it's actually very difficult to
do so black keeps pushing I improve my
pieces black plays 97 so here I played
kind of a normal issue I would call it
but I did have an alternative which
might have been strong as well again I
would call this idea sort of strategic
in that it's an idea where if you can
get this sort of thing in it often means
you can even be strategically winning we
would call it right like you get this in
and off your opponent's just in big
trouble
so what piece can white activate here
it's kind of a difficult right the
night's not amazing but it's on a decent
square it's as good as it's gonna get
right the bishops doing its job
protecting this pawn these guys are not
really that and easy to improve what can
be improved possibly the queen kidnapped
will be improved i I played Queenie to
to give you an idea but even on e2 I
wasn't sure I was improving myself that
much to be honest I was playing it
because I didn't see what black was
gonna do and I thought Queen e2 was
definitely better than Queen on d1
that's why I played it I don't think
it's a terrible move but I had another
possibility which I spent some time on
here in which my opponent surely was not
happy to allow but he probably didn't
have much of a choice right if he
doesn't get his knight in the game he
probably just loses this is the kind of
move that's easy to forget about but
basically if I can play Bishop e6 check
for example maybe play g4 h3 to complete
a little if I ever lock up the Kings
side completely black can almost resign
it sounds like a lot that sounds like an
overstatement but basically if I get in
rook b6 eventually I'm gonna crash
through on the clean side for sure right
so if Black has 0 kind of put in the
Kings side it's basically a
strategically lost game so if I can do
something like this exchange off my bad
Bishop it could be good the only danger
is that this Bishop is also guarding my
king I think what worried me during the
game was something like this some
nonsense
along these lines but I think I could
have just been greedy and just said ah
whatever I'm just taking everything but
it's hard to do this during a game
during a game you don't know a lock on a
play you know but sometimes not such a
big deal but okay I didn't have to play
Bishop h3 and I didn't I think Queen e2
black played Knight here and here I
decided to take the pawn yeah Brooke b6
I allow rook a 6 I didn't see anything
clear I don't really want to put this
pawn from here to here actually I
thought that would be good for blood I'd
like to have a past a pawn if at all
possible so I took this pawn these kind
of moves by the way sometimes are
surprising to people but it actually
forces black to make a tough decision if
black takes with the Jeep on I can play
for example King h1 rook g1 how is black
ever gonna get at my kingdom almost
impossible right
I even have moves like rook g1 Knight f2
Queen f1 it looks ridiculous but black
is completely paralyzed over here and if
I could get in Bishop h3 just to give
you an idea what I'm talking about here
so I'm gonna play a million moves in a
row I hope you guys will excuse me but
just to show you I'd also like to point
out that black is very few useful moves
here if I get in Bishop h3 here it's
just nothing right black has no attack
and very simple to play for white no
probably just lost
so obviously blacks not going to just
sit but there aren't that many useful
things to do here it's gonna be very
very difficult to ever attack me so
black played a very understandable move
trying to keep the game complicated
right when you have a position you don't
like it's very important to at least
make it so you don't have to just suffer
right you want a game that's complicated
but objectively this is also rough and
that's one of the purposes of Queen e2
by the way that I I wanted black to have
to move here because black I didn't see
that many great moves I have plenty of
improvements I can play King h1 next I
can play Bishop h3 is still in there I
have a lot of moves black does not so he
had to make this decision of allowing
this pawn capture but here I think black
White has a pretty strong move
what is the drawback of playing EF
yes indeed
so you pretty much have to take if you
ever allow East six it's usually just
goodnight Irene kinda so you must take
and here actually I had a huge choice I
could take on e5 but I didn't like
getting pinned Queen takes look just
awkward but my whole idea was to take
the C pawn
the idea being then now b7 is super weak
and if I absolutely must I can play 96
and snag this Bishop often without this
Bishop attacking is very difficult it's
kind of the idea so I thought that even
though this looks kind of double-edged I
thought that ultimately this should be
quite moved for a while and I was
correct however unfortunately for myself
I made my life a lot harder with my next
move so my main choice was I could
either defend this knight or I could
play 96 getting rid of this guy one
choice is not good and unfortunately
what I played so you guys are gonna find
the superior choice
yeah it's funny when I look at this now
like I'm like really I played that but
you know sometimes during a game things
are murkier you kind of see ghosts
you're like oh I don't want to allow
that even without calculating it
properly kind of thing not to excuse
myself but this ship before is one of
the moves I looked at it's not a bad
move
I think rook b5 is even stronger because
then I can play Bishop before next and
it looks a little weird but black has no
way to ever take advantage of this so
rook b5 would have been very strong but
for some reason I panicked here and I
thought I had to do something quicker
and it's just not true cuz black just
doesn't have a threat even if black
plays g4 so what there's nothing really
happening there's no real threat my
bishop on g2 may look ridiculous
but it keeps my king very very safe and
it's one of the perks to have to playing
this line in the first place but why I
played here and now the game just became
a mess black played here
so here I had a choice I could have
played h4 I thought forever on this move
the idea being that it looks kind of
almost suicidal but the idea is that now
if tix I can play Bishop h3 and if g4 I
can take and take but I saw these pawns
and I think something inside me was like
no Josh just don't do it I had the
nightmare the other night about these
three pawns you don't want to end up
living that that scenario but ultimately
you can actually just do this and I
think it was decent uh-oh I also I could
take with the bishop and this I looked
at as well again I was scared about
efore and the Queen coming in but
sometimes when you're you have a
position you think is really good you'll
often go way out of your way to prevent
counter play this is a GM tendency in
particular I'm definitely but I'm
definitely guilty of doing this win
sometimes you have to allow your
opponent to do a couple things
you know you can't just run over them
with no counter play that's just not
realistic so I had to allow some of this
and probably it would have been good but
the move I played was was I was kind of
interesting Bishop age three
it looks logical I'm just defending my
pawn this pawn by the way is a real
thorn in black side if he doesn't get
rid of it
but of course he's an active player he
has to go for it so he plays d4 so the
question is how to handle this advance
because it looks kind of scary if black
ever takes and plays G for my bishops
gonna feel a little frightened and
bishops are really a pain when they feel
frightened ly they go kind of crazy with
it
yeah and here I realize things were not
so easy I had messed up I had not played
this the best way but I still have to
find a move right I could just try to
offer a draw but that seemed a little
silly so what to do
make the best of the situation which is
a lot of what chesses rugby six but does
that address the problem of takes up
three and g4 I don't know I mean it's
maybe have four hangs in those lines but
trying to remember exactly what I was
afraid of whether I was afraid of like
III first or Czech first I was afraid of
something I can promise you this I think
what I was afraid of just to give you an
idea I'm not sure about the check first
that's a tricky one I think maybe the
check so give the check and then this
one and this yeah this I did not like
probably better with the Queen back on
c7 actually but yeah I did not want any
piece of this this to me look like a
nightmare so yeah rook b6 was not my
move I decided to give back a little bit
I realized you know what if blah if I
give black time to play g4 and just play
up three I'm just gonna have a miserable
life so I'm like you know what come at
me g4
f 3 so i sack a piece I didn't want to
sack a piece it wasn't my intention when
I woke up that morning but at the same
and it looks kind of weird cuz I don't
have a single healthy pawn all my pawns
have some varying degree of sickness
some ailments but I have a lot of them
and sometimes just having lots of pawns
can actually be stronger than you think
like there's this tendency where it's
like oh all the puns are weak we assume
they all fall at once but they don't
Black has to spend moves taking them and
that's kind of the downfall here so
black actually had a very the the best
move for black was Queen c6 and after
that probably it's more draw us than not
I think the line went Bishop c3 rook
takes c6 route b6 and I win a piece I
win my piece back but all my pawns just
kind of fall and okay I'm still
technically up a pawn but these are it's
closer to a draw than a win let's put it
that way
that being said Black has to find you
know find it in his heart to give back
the piece it's not it was such an easy
decision psychologically instead black
took this immediately but now after rook
takes b7 there are some problems and all
of a sudden this a pawn is absolute
monster it's glad I held on to that and
it's just not so easy because blacks
king is actually a weaker than mine
despite being up a piece so he played
here
I played route b6 black took but here I
found a very very nice variation
yes indeed so if five so yeah Ricca fate
was one of the moves I expected but I
can't oh yeah this move I missed I think
during the game this was pretty strong
but I didn't see this one at all but I
think yeah rook takes c6 then 94 is
actually quite nasty so I have to be
careful I still have this move though
but yeah if I can also just take this
this night I think and if if ruk takes I
forget exactly what my idea was oh yeah
I can always play Bishop f4 and kind of
shield myself but again this was a
little bit tricky but this was the move
I expected but now believe it or not
this is a very tricky choice because I
have three pieces I can take here and I
can tell you that very rarely is taking
all of them okay usually something's
wrong with one of them so the question
is to find which piece do you capture
first so many captures so little time
etc etc
it's hard to decline a real check yeah
this was a tricky moment because neither
of us had a lot of time here and the
game was still quite complicated he had
less time than me thankfully which
helped out a lot
we have pawn takes rook is originally
what I wanted to play because now it's I
have two connected pawns and look
beautiful but after this move I wasn't
sure what to do
b7 looks nice but even rook a fate might
be playable and it's some just complete
mess so none of that really appealed to
me and yeah if takes the knight which I
also wanted to play there was some issue
maybe just rook takes and give up the
piece back and it was complicated at the
least so I did take this real quick
check King age 7 and this was kind of
the key move
this was the mover when I saw this move
I knew okay I got this kind of like
alright my position will be good it's
hard when everything's hanging right but
luckily black is a very strong threat
which makes your options more limited
what is blacks very strong threat taking
the rook with mate
so you your move ideally you should
prevent that Queen f3 I think a loud
rook b3 I want to say that is Czech I
wasn't sure I thought I found a nicer
move with Queen g2 because now there are
often moves like rook g1 and latter isin
as well which can be quite strong so
yeah rookie 6 which was what I expected
takes takes rook g1 and this is the key
that I don't try to trade rooks because
if I trade rooks my king is very exposed
right but if I keep the rooks on the
board then blacks King is just super
weak and then I can probably just push
my a pawn at my leisure sort of and also
it's hard to not let me trade anything
for example if Queen f7 I can just take
on g7 and play Bishop c3 and it's just
over because the pin so instead he
played this one pawn takes Knight so
it's very important that after rook
takes D - I have mate he took back rook
g1 and this is the setup I liked this is
the one I saw basically my King is
completely safe and I'm threatening his
King so yeah having the two pawns is
nice even though they're doubled but the
key that's gonna make me let me win more
easily as that blacks king is very weak
and that's kind of the key to this
position more than the pawns almost if I
didn't have any pawns it would be harder
to win obviously but you know making
sure blacks passive and defending
against make threats and pushing my
pawns that's kind of the key so black
played Queen back to f7 I gave a check I
like to centralize my pieces
came back mr. v3 note how I'm making
sure I'm covering every single diagonal
so black objectively maybe should try to
trade Queens but the problem is then I
can just put upon in a7 and with the
bishop here that's gonna be pretty much
just dead this is one of those
situations where if it's a rook endgame
it screams way more complicated but as
long as there are bishops on the board
with a pawn here it's just quite too
much so black played rook b3 so how did
how did I try to finish things
because it's weird like blacks King is
cornered but it's not that easy to
actually give Czech man the Queen on e4
is perfect you don't want to mess with a
perfect piece rook where rook g6 I'll be
a little nervous about playing oh geez
that's the thing I don't think I would
consider it like I just wouldn't
consider it because it's like well what
if rook takes c3 then check then maybe
it works but then I have to allow King
g8 and check here you said I mean it's
just like no no no basically things can
go wrong if you do things like that
bishop before is definitely a pretty
nice-looking move the only thing is
after takes takes you've exchanged the
bishops right which means you better up
mate or a forest win probably you do but
I'm not a hundred percent sure
I don't know it's kind of annoying right
it looks really nice but there's no
immediate mate and again if you allow
queen of three allow queen trade drawing
chances as increase very rapidly but
now of a sudden black is kind of a
problem right because this pin is
actually very difficult to get rid of
rook takes a three but there was a last
trick
how does why to finish the game so this
is why people play it like there's a
very specific reason why people resign
at certain times so he could resign here
pretty easily but he decided to take my
pawn first and this was actually the
reason if work takes f6 it looks like a
killer right but the problem is that
here black has an escape which is that
black just keeps giving checks and the
King can't get out you could take this
rook but then I take and take right so
it's just a drum so again it's why you
always have to be careful to the very
last moment luckily there's another move
which makes black resign a lot easier
because that was the key rook f1 I
wasn't actually threatening rook takes
f6 that wasn't my idea what was the idea
yeah Bishop d4 does the trick because
now if you exchange for I can just take
your queen
there's no maid or anything weird with
the rope so I did double check that cuz
you know I've seen weird things but okay
yeah and now the problem is rook takes
up six is a threat and then my rook can
block with checks and Bishop takes f6 is
a check it's just too many threats so
that was then but again I mean I'm
really complicated game it looked kind
of iffy for me for a little while and
again it's just one of those positions
where you know it's hard to figure
everything out I couldn't figure it out
I don't think my opponent who knew those
positions pretty well figured it all out
but the key is that you just have to
take it one move at a time you know you
want to have a general plan you want to
have an underlying theme you want to
know when the position changes like when
black played f4 remember it was like
trumpets sound like okay I have to play
Queen side he has to play King side but
the key is to make sure that every
decision you make the best decision you
can at that time if you're not sure what
to do just don't make your position
worse try to improve your position try
to play on your side of the board but
you know just try not to make a bad
decision if you're not sure what the
best decision is just don't weaken your
position don't make it worse I'd say
that that's how people lose
strategically more often than not it's
not that they're make they're not
finding a great strategic ideas that
they're weakening their position for no
reason it's that they're you know
allowing their opponent to do a little
too much so if you can take anything
from this game it's that I didn't
understand my position perfectly
whatsoever but I took it one move at a
time I mostly avoided blunders obviously
when we were both low on time the game
they're crazy i sacked the piece but
even so I felt like even during that
time black had the difficult position to
play and it was because earlier I just
somehow found a way to you know not make
my position worse so sometimes that's
kind of what you have to do
alright guys I hope you enjoyed it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]